bonjour alors aujourd'hui je vais vous
parler de d'apprentissage
d'apprentissage en particulier de la
musique et la musique c'est ma grande
passion
mais la fête elle est un petit peu
gâchée parce que la musique passe par le
solfège et c'est douloureux et c'est
décourageant
je sais pas si ça parle à quelques
personnes dans la salle mais j'ai eu la
grande chance de rencontrer une personne
qui m'a inspiré qui s'appelle janot
védrine qui était un pianiste de jazz
hors pair qui était extrêmement modeste
et son talent d'égalé que sa modestie
quand il se mettait face à un piano
c'était génial janot il me donnait des
cours dans un petit magasin rue de la
treille à clermont et il m'apprenait la
musique sans parler de notes
il évitait de parler note il me parlait
de textures de sensations et montrer
comment les créer il avait aussi le
génie de pas me parler de solfège c'est
à dire il connaissait le solfège mais il
n'en parlait pas ça m'a amené à faire ce
constat c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de
grands musiciens qui en fait ne savent
pas du tout les runes une note de
partition mais comment ils font parce
que ils jouent librement
il joue il créer librement
ça veut dire peut-être que il ya
d'autres manières de penser la musique
d'autres manières de fonctionner
d'autres manières de voir la musique
nos chemins se sont séparés avec jeannot
et j'ai continué à apprendre la musique
tout seul de manière personnelle de
manière à matrix mais toujours en me
posant la question quel genre de système
pourrait me corresponde et c'est là en
fait je suis mis à dessiner des formes
jeu
aperçu que ça marchait pour moi en fait
ça m'aidait à progresser et j'ai
développé une sorte de méthode
artisanale et personnel vous avez déjà
entendu parler du cercle chromatique
c'est la base de ma représentation
[Musique]
c'est comme ça que la musique pour moi a
commencé à prendre forme et ça m'a aidé
à comprendre la musique et des choses
que je ne comprenais pas précédemment
ça m'a permis de comprendre des
musiciens que j'admire et comme par
exemple
miles davis voilà soad pour moi c'est un
pentagramme ce morceau est basée sur un
accord qu'on appelle la corse soit y'a
pas d'autres termes qui était inventée
par le le pianiste bill evans et ben
quand on joue cet accord c'est difficile
de le visualiser sur un piano et quand
on joue d'une manière géométrique comme
la mienne qui est basé sur le cercle
chromatique on voit un pentagramme giant
steps giant steps de john coltrane c'est
un morceau qui est très difficile à
mémoriser
lorsqu'on ne comprend pas la structure
qu'est ce qu'il fait il divise la gamme
par trois et il va développer la
structure du morceau et les progressions
d'accords sur cette division par trois
peut-être que ce que je raconte ça vous
parle ou ça vous parle pas mais vous
comprenez qu'on prenait l'idée giant
steps est très intéressant parce que le
fait de prendre des éléments musicaux et
de les transposer les décalés ça paraît
pas très naturel ça paraît des pas de
géants sa part et des grands intervalles
et c'est peut-être pour ça que que john
coltrane nommé ce morceau giants tête
des pas de géant herbie hancock une
forme d'harmonisation kirby hancock
utilise tout le temps on voit une
symétrie dans cette forme plus
simplement la structure du blues
certains musiciens peut-être joue du
blues dans la salle passée la
représentation de la structure du blues
sur un cercle chromatique
alors moi c'est une manière personnelle
de voir la musique mais je me suis dit
est ce que ça pourrait peut-être pas
aider d'autres personnes
et c'est là où j'ai voulu faire une
expérience c'est à dire j'ai développé
une première interface interactive où on
joue et on voit sur un écran parce que
l'on joue mais de manière avec des
formes j'ai développé cette interface et
j'ai voulu le tester donc j'ai pris un
échantillon représentatif de la
population mondiale qui ne connaît pas
la musique le monde est divisé en deux y
en a qui jouent de la musique d'autres
qui ne la joue pas et j'ai pris ma nièce
je vous présente ma nièce elle a trois
ans et demi sur cette photo elle ne
connaît rien au solfège vraiment rien
elle a jamais joué une note de musique
et là je vais vous montrer une vidéo où
ses premières notes de musique qu'elle
va jouer sur un piano
comment ça se passe je lui montre une
forme qui en fait un ta g sans plus
d'explications je lui dis joue cette
forme forme et donc jeu explique la
règle du jeu
donc au début c'était un peu archaïque
c'était vous avez vu c'est avec tes
transparent
et elle va commencer à jouer
observez un petit peu comme elle est
attentive son regard est axée sur
l'écran et sur le piano et qu'est ce qui
se passe c'est que de manière
instinctive elle va être capable de
reproduire une forme et pour elle ça va
être complètement jeu logique de jouer
une forme en six minutes
elle découvre un concept fondamental de
la musique qui est là pentatonique
majeur qui est un concept fondamental
dans la compréhension de la musique d'un
point de vue mélodique et aussi dans la
proche de l'improvisation musicale
un enfant de 4 ans à une durée
d'attention d'à peu près six minutes il
va vouloir jouer avec cette forme de jeu
elle va découvrir un concept qui avec la
méthode traditionnelle prendrait cinq à
sept ans alors tout ça pose le problème
de de l'apprentissage d'autres méthodes
n'explique pas tout la musique mais elle
permet de prendre des raccourcis
l'apprentissage
les pédagogues se décompose en trois
éléments une codification une
représentation mentale et l'expression
je vais prendre l'exemple de l'écriture
pour vous aider à comprendre l'écriture
on va utiliser une codification qui va
nous aider à former une représentation
mentale de l'écriture on va utiliser des
lettres et la représentation mentale ça
va être le fait de former des mots en
agrégeant des lettres on va former des
phrases en agrégeant des mots on va
ensuite créé des expressions et une fois
que l'élève s'est approprié ce système
il va être capable de créer des
formulations personnel et de s'exprimer
de manière autonome librement
là on voit que la méthode traditionnelle
de l'apprentissage de la musique court
circuite cette phase d'appropriation
on nous demande de maîtriser un système
de notation qui est très compliqué et
les petites notes avec des portés et on
va nous demander de répéter ses notes et
on nous dit que c'est l'expression de la
musique on apprend à répéter on
n'apprend pas à comprendre
ce système de notation qui n'est pas
intuitif en fait fait que l'effort
d'apprentissage est en grande partie
axée sur la compréhension de ce système
de notation plutôt que d'axer le
l'effort d'apprentissage sur
l'expérimentation de la musique
l'exploration ou sa compréhension je
voudrais vous parler de la synesthésie
qu'est ce que ça veut dire la
synesthésie c'est le fait de faire des
ponts entre les sens c'est de prendre
des paramètres musicaux de prendre des
paramètres visuel est de créer une table
de correspondance de faire des lignes
entre ces zélés ces paramètres
et bien c'est quelque chose quand fait
que l'on peut développer sous forme d'
interface une interface qui essaient de
modéliser cette approche cinéaste
éthiques
je vais vous donner quelques exemples
alors voyez que ces photos réalistes et
qu'on va pouvoir manipuler ces éléments
je vais jouer un accord majeur par
exemple ça créé une forme j'ai joué un
quart et je joue un pentagramme
[Musique]
voilà c'est cette approche dans cette
interface on a voulu aller un petit peu
plus loin on a voulu en fait traduire
des textures musicales en texture visuel
donc par exemple je joue un accord
majeur qui est un accord stable qui
épure on va le voir com de com de l'or
un petit peu comme sur les balcons de
l'opéra
le carré ça va être du velours
exactement comme les sièges sur lesquels
vous êtes assis pourquoi parce que c'est
une harmonie qui est à la fois douce à
la fois triste un petit peu dissonante
mais qui aussi lourde et on va pouvoir
faire des résolutions comme ceux ci par
exemple
donc ça transforme complètement en fait
la proche de la musique un accord quand
il est gay il est comme ça
quand ils les tristes on va créer des
effets d'ombrés en fait et ensuite les
effets de dissonance est de consonance
vont être lié à des effets de texture la
dissonance qui exprime la l'instabilité
harmonique
on va faire une texture rugueuse non
réfléchissantes pour la consonance on va
modélisés avec une texture lisse et
réfléchissantes
si ça peut aider
rien qu'une seule personne à comprendre
certains concepts de musique comme agnès
par exemple eh bien je serai ravi je
serais très content
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
yj